alright hello everyone
first I want to thanks for this
opportunity to present our work here so
today I want to talk to you about our
new master simple open source measure to
do highly multiplex imagery on tissue so
we call it a tissue slices okay so I
just want to briefly go through the
master with you
if you can go to the next section right
now so the cyclic sightsee is short for
cycling in your core essence basically
what you try to do here is just like
your regular engine for essence but you
can do it in multiple time the reason we
can do this is we use a chemistry that
combine hydrogen peroxide past a little
bit sodium hydroxide so that will
effectively remove all the floral after
you done with standing so as you can see
here in the next section we have four
cycle or four step on one cycle first
you do your standing which the floral
come to the intrabody
then you can stand with your nucleus
that's with first order P anything you
want then later on you can try to image
all the things then you've got your
first image done then in the last step
of the cycle you try to erase these
things and the us using the chemistry we
are talking about a hydrogen peroxide
reagent so then you can repeat this
cycle multiple time as you can see so
probably need to do time here I just try
to show you a quick example that we have
a slide actually is tongue so human
tongue so we before you do the standing
you can start to see some background
fluorescence but it's ok because we
recall all this information before you
stand
and that after you standing you can
compare before and after and the third
thing you can do is you can erase all
this signal afterward and the dance then
again with a new antibody now you can
start to see all the changes in the
standing pattern and you can do this so
on and so forth and the good thing of
this method is it's very simple so it's
not you don't require any special
instrument and it's very effective as
you can see right here Oh most powerful
we has been test being effectively move
in the short amount time in time scale
here we are talking about one hour and
then we test the market offer for that
all work with the same chemistry so you
can pretty much just buy any kind of the
commercial antibody that's conjugate
with the fluorophore we indicate here
then do your cyclic in no fluorescence
so maybe some people worry about
indigeneity because all this kind of
chemistry may destroy your sample and
the whipping has to be very carefully as
you can see down in the corner here do
it again so you can see right here the
figures show that after form of standing
we try to do the same antibody again and
again we don't see a significant
difference but only caveat maybe
Congress this measure sinks the sample
to require multiple ton of standing so
you can see right on here in your left
thumb Konan so some tissue maybe go over
multiple cycle within test up to 20
cycles now some tissue may be form off
in like a or seven cycle so this need to
be further optimization but for the old
tissue reading test that we can go
through like this the seventh cycle we
saw any problem so from here I want to
show you one things really quick because
this is nothing different from your
tradition
you know for essence so you can do a
really high resolution or high quality
image and even get subcellular
localization so here I just quickly show
you a ten cycle standing that with the
various marker and now we can bring in
to try to see a marker for example like
this case we do a Lommy extending or
viral anything or each of the human you
can see a clear compartment between your
by 19 and the he could even as well us
for the yummy and you can see a nice
green surround your nucleus that's
indicated right subcellular localization
and the if you are thinking so for this
kind of message you not only get a nice
picture of your sample but also we
developed some homemade squid to allow
you to quantify your data even single
cell level so now you can get market
post reading in single cell as here is
the one example we do a you know
standing for for given color and then we
can represent it here as the foie gras
so now you can know each standing and in
this case we actually can do this for at
least 20 marker so you can do some sort
of high dimensional clustering analysis
as you can show here to show nice and
subcellular localization as well as
population leasing your cell and that
the one interesting apart ation for this
kind of massive definite is unlike any
more oncology side you can try to stock
it differentiate so in this case we have
a renal cell carcinoma here so we can
differentiate humor versus the stroma or
the immune cell very clearly so now we
can quantify all this though in
different compartment in a relatively
easy way in the two also further
demonstrate the power of our NASA we try
to use the tissue microarray with
various type of tissue and now we can
start to see this kind of beautiful
representation although I don't have
time to go through the people
here but now we color coded each sample
we stiffen color in the trophy which we
send a high dimensional data in a two
dimensional way and then all you can see
that this master clearly separate
different tissue out from each other but
for some case we do see uh some some
interaction between different tissue
that's indicating you might have the
degeneration of the human in this case
and the oldest kind of the measure can
be used to detail study your like to
further differentiation tissue to teach
your variation as well as a lot of
appreciation week we cannot describe
right here okay for the last thing I
want to show you is so as many of you
may know the fiddle generally even a
human tissue may be an important topic
that people want to understand and we
are thinking on answer will be
particularly useful in this case because
now we just show you one or actually
this is the three color standing we try
to label the EGFR or the first order and
also the new car standing try to see how
much heat or energy you can get from
this particular tumor this is the gbn
sample that we got from the patient so
you can see some few more strongly stand
for one marker versus the other but it's
hard to do that in a traditional
pathology way because you typically just
look at multiple region and even try to
come up with the conclusion if we can
use the armature we pretty much just
scan order sample then we can resend a
quantitative analysis of how energy
narrative in here we show us three
different marker try to see how the
spatial heterogeneity you can go from a
tissue and then we can do a more
detailed
quantification analysis to show like
it's different cluster in a special and
also try to look at quantitatively how
this cluster represent in different
special origin all this can be done with
relatively simple experimental procedure
as well
as our software will be open to property
so you can try to see if you found this
interesting and we are happy to help you
to set up your own experiment and to
that I want to thank my funding source
and also my device that Peters over and
also their Harvard left of system
pharmacology thanks for your attention